yeah hello and welcome to the new
playing veteranos veteran ruse veteran
Russ okay so a veteran Russian player so
we're getting there
so what is he doing okay so I got the
got the my Roxy point C blink now but
that plan does a piece guy guys whatever
I've had this so often two splendas a
piece
so we add how often you get that on the
ward mmm yeah this is actually what some
other player had to try it against me
in an earlier game
yeah
black resigns sure there was a short
game it's the identical turn already a
game that I had like maybe three weeks
ago or something something like that I
don't know that g4 is very common
blunder in this position usually black
goes Bishop d7 here or tanks and this is
it's just a piece Jim and 97 is actually
good yeah I should do that next time
yeah when I get it yeah just take this
and then I don't even have any
structural issues f3 is of course also
just a piece but it's if he if he
doesn't give me the Queen to resign then
at least in a position like that my pawn
structure is a mess and I have to still
win it okay it's up it's a full piece
six for one pawn but yeah anyway yeah
avoid Knight g4 is the is the thing to
learn from that one thanks for watching